how about some good news the raiders
play tomorrow they welcome an opponent
and fans into allegion stadium for the
first time in history it's going to be a
learning experience for both the fans
and the team john treach has a preview
on tomorrow's preseason raiders game
against the seahawks
thanks so much brian we are a city full
of exhibitionists especially on
saturdays the raiders play an exhibition
game against the seahawks in theory it
means nothing in progress toward
normalcy it means everything tomorrow
the town turns up the volume on raiders
and potentially pacific northwest sports
enthusiasts too the raiders and seahawks
collided in the first preseason game
since 2019 in the first ever in las
vegas and the inaugural game where there
is both a scoreboard and fans in the
stands for being just a friendly
exhibition there's a lot to learn
especially when you're on the defense
with a lot to prove
hey we finally get to go against
somebody else and compete against
somebody else you know that's trying to
beat us so we gotta you know do the same
thing for them and i think you know as a
defense and as a team we're going to be
prepared uh you know there's going to be
some mistakes because you know this it's
a learning curve for everybody
especially on this defensive side but
you know hopefully you know as the game
goes and the more games we get
the defense has just turned into one of
those defenses everybody like hey
those guys flying around and not a weak
link of the
other team
speaking of history has there ever been
a preseason game featuring marie osmond
carlos santana and super fan grillarilla
should be an adventurous night in las
vegas with family fun and experiences
more suitable for the 18 plus crowd
brian weren't they all just at
lollapalooza
if you're planning to go to tomorrow's
game get there early officials advise
that you get to allegion stadium at
least three hours before kickoff
thousands who attend the last couple of
major events at the stadium dealt with
traffic and parking problems county
commissioner michael naft who represents
the area says they're making several
changes around allegiant like moving the
rideshare lot to the other side of the
stadium we'll see how it goes